so some say kamala harris kamala harris
whatever we're going with is kind of
phony because she can't even pronounce
her own first
name it changes but she'd like you to
know that despite appearances she does
have some pretty deep principles
but we are united by the fundamental
belief
that every human being is of infinite
worth
deserving of compassion dignity
and respect but there was a caveat
unstated at the time
that everyone deserves dignity and
respect
except the people who work for kamala
harris
they don't get it and now they're going
on the record to explain
one staffer in her office quote had a
sense of paranoia that you never knew
when she was going to snap at you
surprised to learn that another said
employees were quote so stressed out
that they were making themselves
sick so kamala harris
champion of women actually was
marinating in a toxic
stew of toxic masculinity
jesse kelly is sophisticated enough to
understand what this is about he's the
host of the jesse kelly show he joins us
tonight jessie
thanks for coming on are you surprised
to learn that
kamala harris if that's what she's going
by is like the worst boss in washington
and nasty to the people who work for her
it's the most predictable thing in the
world tucker everybody watching you
right now
has worked for or worked with somebody
who just has ambition just dripping off
of their pores and that's kamala harris
those types of people
will do anything to get ahead they treat
their bosses like crap they treat their
employees like crap
that's why she knifed joe biden in the
debate with all that race nonsense there
was no need to do that
it's the same reason she tackles like a
dead hyena every time she's asked an
uncomfortable question
it's the same reason she started out her
political career
as willie brown's bratwurst bond kamala
harris will do anything to get ahead
i gotta say when i look at her i you can
just you can feel the fear
and false people are always afraid
because they're terrified you'll find
out who they really are people who don't
actually know how to pronounce their own
first names or who grew up in canada and
pretend they didn't
she always seems like she's terrified of
being exposed
well she doesn't believe in anything and
like you said people without any
grounding
they're really worried about getting
called out on it kamala harris is always
painted as this far left winger
if kamala harris thought her political
ambitions would do better on the right
kamala harris would be to the right of
barry goldwater tomorrow
she believes in absolutely nothing
except for kamala harris that's all
she's ever been and so
any staffer she doesn't look at them
like people like a secretary or an
assistant
they're all just stepping stones she can
stomp on on the way to the top job
but she'll be miserable there too as
soon as they throw poor joe out the back
door and kamala sits in the oval office
she'll hate that too she'll move on to
something else
it would be funny that's such a good
point about going there it'd be funny to
like bribe her poster to convince her
that actually the one issue she could
ride to national prominence is like an
attack on circumcision or someone's
like bizarre and obscure like that and
watch her give the impassioned speech
she was throwing people in prison all
day long in california as this absolute
ball-busting cop throwing people in jail
for for
anything she could possibly think of and
now she goes to the senate she's the
most left-wing senator this woman
doesn't believe
in anything except for achieving the
next thing and like i said
everybody watching is already thinking
of somebody they know someone in their
life like that they're always terrible
people
universally no that's you're absolutely
right we shouldn't pretend that she's
especially unusual
you know her uh jessie kelly great to
see you tonight thank you for doing that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else